mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
pi pi pi pi
write an equation that uses pi exactly
four times and equals zero
do the same thing for one and two
and see how high you can go
for a real challenge solve for any
integer n
[Music]
you can use common mathematical
operations limited to the following
table
these are standard functions you would
find on an android calculator
i think many people who suggested
similar problems including tai ci qiung
peter and the puzzling stack exchange
community
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started with an equation for
zero
here's one of the many equations you
could have written
pi plus pi minus pi minus pi is equal to
zero
from here rather than writing formulas
for specific numbers let's write a
general formula for any positive integer
n
to do that we'll solve a similar problem
how can you make n from three copies of
two
there's a clever solution from the nobel
laureate physicist paul derock
here was his formula
let's write the following
negative log base 2
of log base 2
now we are going to iterate the square
root function a total of n times
in the end we're going to evaluate the
square root of 2.
this exactly equals n
why is that
let's understand the formula by working
through this nested square root
recall that the square root of 2 is
equal to 2 to the power of 1 half
therefore the square root of the square
root of 2 is equal to 2 to the power of
1 over 2 squared
if we iterate the square root function a
total of n times we'll end up with 2 to
the power of 1 over 2 to the power of n
this is also written as 2 to the power
of negative n
we now evaluate log base 2 of this which
will be equal to 2 to the power of
negative n
evaluating log base 2 again we get
negative n
then the opposite of negative n is equal
to n
therefore this formula is exactly true
now let's solve our problem with pi
one thing we can do is we can change the
base of this logarithm and the argument
in this nested square root to both be pi
both of these will cancel out
we can then rewrite 2 as equaling
negative cosine of pi minus cosine of pi
we thus have a valid expression that
uses pi a total of 4 times
this will give all positive integers n
we can change the negative sign into a
positive to get all negative values of n
but we have one problem
the logarithm function is using a base
of 2.
log base 2 doesn't appear on a standard
android calculator
so how do we get around this
we'll use the change of base formula for
logarithms
log base 2 of x is equal to the natural
log of x all over the natural log of 2.
we'll use this formula and substitute in
we end up with the following fraction
now here we have log base pi so we'll
again use the change of base formula
so now let's substitute that in and put
everything in terms of the natural
logarithm
now we have a negative sign at the
beginning which we can cleverly
eliminate by taking the reciprocal of
this argument
this will make the formula a little bit
easier to read
we now have a formula for all positive
integers n
then if we wanted to get all negative
integers we simply have a negative sign
you can also see that if n is equal to 0
this entire thing will actually evaluate
to b0 as well
so we have one simple formula and it
uses pi exactly four times
incredible
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you